[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
it is a remarkable moment to see the
easing of tensions between Iran and
Saudi Arabia because for a number of
years they have very much been in direct
conflict as well as indirect conflict in
other parts of the Middle East and
anything that can be done to reduce the
kinds of violence that we see in Yemen
in Syria Iraq Lebanon between Iran and
Saudi Arabia directly is of benefit not
just to the people in the region but
also to the world
foreign
thank you
intense diplomatic efforts are ongoing
at different levels to bring the
conflict in Yemen to an end
we are currently witnessing renewed
Regional diplomatic momentum as well as
a step change in the scope and depth of
the discussions
thank you